see that they're giving us two terms a
sub three equals eleven that's the value
of the third term and a sub eight equals
21
so in this video I'm going to show you
an easier method before you might have
used this formula over here and written
a system of equations but what I want to
show you is that when you're dealing
with arithmetic sequences what you're
really dealing with is you're dealing
with terms that are going up by a
constant amount a constant difference as
they call it and that difference is
actually the slope so for example if we
were to diagram this out you can see
that you're taking 11 and then you're
adding the same quantity each time until
you get to the next term X term next
term until you get to the eighth term
which is you know 21 but if we were to
plot these points out what you would see
is you'd have a sub 3 okay the third
term would be up here at 11 and then a
sub 8 four five six seven eight is gonna
be up here at 21 and so you can see
they're going up at a constant rate okay
and that's the slope so we're gonna
write the equation of a line using the
slope and the y-intercept so that's the
technique we're gonna be doing so again
we're just going to coordinate eyes
these points turn them into coordinates
okay so switching forms from the
sequence notation to just coordinate
notation and we're going to use our
slope formula so y2 minus y1 over x2
minus x1 which gives us 21 minus 11 over
eight minus three which gives us what
that's ten over five which equals two so
we know this is going up at a constant
rate of two each time okay to get to the
next term and then what we can do is we
can use our slope intercept form of a
line y equals MX plus B and we can say
alright we know we're going up by two so
that's our slope that's our M value and
pick one of the points either this point
or this point I'm gonna pick the first
one so when y is 11 X is 3 and we can
solve for B okay so that's going to be
11 equals 6 plus B subtract 6 from both
sides and you can see that B equals 5
I'm just going to put that back in so we
have y equals 2x plus 5 now let's switch
back to the sequence notation which is
going to look like this a sub N equals 2
times n plus 5 okay so n is what term
that you're on and
sub n is the value of that term and you
can test it out so if I put three in
that's going to be 2 times 3 is 6 plus 5
is 11 if we put 8 in we get 2 times 8 is
16 plus 5 is 21 and you can see that it
checks out but basically what we're
doing is we're using the concept that
arithmetic sequences are linear they're
going up you know at a constant rate and
that constant rate is a slope so I hoped
you understand this video a lot better
about how to work with arithmetic
sequences subscribe to the channel check
out more math tutoring videos on my
youtube channel Mario's math tutoring I
look forward to helping you in the
future videos I'll talk to you soon